Olympic sprinter Oscar Pistorius has been charged with murder...
...after the shooting death of his girlfriend in his home in South Africa.
Local police told the AP that officers received a call around 3 AM,...
...saying there had been a shooting at the runner's house.
They later recovered a nine millimeter gun at the double amputee's home.
Talent management company confirmed that the victim of the shooting...
...is 29-year-old model Reeva Steenkamp.
Known as the Blade Runner, Pistorius is expected to appear in court later today.
Reaction from local police.
We can confirm that there was a shooting incident this morning...
...at the home of the well-known paralympic athlete Oscar Pistorius.
At this site we can confirm that a young woman,...
...a 30-year-old woman did die on the scene of gunshot wounds.
A 26-year-old man has been arrested and has been charged with murder.
We've also taken cognizance of the media reports...
...during the course of the morning, of an alleged break-in...
...or that the young lady was allegedly mistaken to be a burglar.
Obviously our forensic investigation is still ongoing.
More background on the Blade Runner,...
...Pistorius was born without fibulas...
...and had his lower legs amputated when he was 11 months old.
He won six paralympic gold medals,...
...racing on prosthetic limbs that were initially banned by track's governing body.
But he was reinstated and allowed to compete in the London Games,...
...becoming the first double amputee runner to compete on the track in the games...
...in the semis of the 400, and he anchored the South African relay team 4 by 400.